ah mais le mec est complètement ce qu'il
veut en fait arrête de dire ça ça c'est
de la psychophobie c'est de la
discrimination envers les personnes qui
ont des troubles psy ou des troubles
mentaux quand tu fais ça tuinsultes pas
la personne dont tu parles tuinsultes
des personnes qui ont une maladie ou qui
ont un problème et ça c'est nul tu
dirais pas traiter quelqu'un de
diabétique ou d'insuffisant rénal voilà
bah pareil des insultes psychophobes il
y en a plein comme ça débile à la base
c'est un terme médical c'est un trouble
du développement intellectuel crétin
c'est pareil le chrétinisme c'est une
forme de retard mental et de handicap
physique al autiste c'est diff c'est pas
une maladie mentale on en reparlera mais
traitez pas les gens d'autistes non plus
ni de skizo donc en plus ça veut pas du
tout dire ce que vous croyez je vous
explique ça en partie 2